[Music]
Brad Pitt is focusing on his family and
work the source tells eetzi the 54 year
old actor is in a great place
personally and professionally after
recently spending time with his six kids
in London where he's currently shooting
his upcoming movie once upon a time in
Hollywood and as far as dating goes the
source reveals Brad is single after his
split from ex Angelina Jolie despite
continued reports that he's dating MIT
professor Neri Oxman quote he has gone
on dates but he's not looking to leap
into a serious relationship at the
moment he is content on his own and
enjoys the quality time he spends with
the children when he isn't working yeah
look at your options and you make the
best decision you carry on ET source
also shares being a father is his number
one job and he knows that he will always
be there for those children
earlier this month Jolie was ordered by
a judge to help prepare Maddox packs
Zahara Shiloh and the twins Knox and
Vivian's relationship with their dad
according to court documents obtained by
ET a judge determined that the kids not
having that relationship is harmful to
them you and your children are your best
friends it's kind of a it's a nice life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]